What was the general good experience?
Will there's diversion,
highlight knockouts,
one of the most ridiculous nightmare of
all time.
When you stand there with your hands
down,
step forward and it's like he was a
comic book scene.
It's like the way you knocked him out.
Like I said about you being a bad guy in
a movie.
It seemed like you were a bad guy in a
boxing movie,
but it didn't make any sense.
You were the guy.
Like if I was say if there's someone was
I was a coach of a good guy and I was
sitting ringside and I was watching you
do that,
we'd be like,
Shit,
okay.
I'm tell you.
Stood over them like that.
I was outside of my body.
I could see me and him standing there
like I was a third person.
I can't explain it,
you know?
And then when I started throwing the
punches,
like I went back into my body and start
welding on the little whatever,
I can't.
I can't explain that feeling
so many different things that happened.
That was a big one too because I got
shared so much online.
Millions and millions of people saw that
online.
They're like,
what in the fuck is this guy got in his
head and that's when they started.
Who is this guy?
While we haven't heard about this
before?
It's like everybody's waking up to the
heavyweight division.
All of sudden it was so true and it was
the perfect convert.
There it is.
I did play it from the beginning.
Jamie.
Here it goes.
Come on.
Straight box skills.
I,
I got boxing skills.
You know,
when the first photo I showed it,
I stayed disciplined.
I didn't abandoned the game plan,
you know,
and I show people that I could box.
Yeah.
And he knows probably the only time I
just really just stay super disciplined.
Not despite,
but this first one,
this part,
right?
This one right here.
I went outside of my body right here.
I'm standing.
Then I came back.
I kid you not.
I don't know what the hell was going on
with me.
That was ridiculous.
It was ridiculous.
He said,
no he didn't.
Yeah,
he was,
uh,
he was quite upset that the strangest
little concoction.
He's got dreadlocks.
They're little like tape.
Yeah,
that seems like that would get in the
way to keep it up.
You know,
the Asians believe in it too.
That was,
that was sweet too.
Then the referee gave me,
I don't
know,
it would have been funnier.
The railroad let go when he wrote to the
other corner,
talk about a movie that would have been.
But you know,
that fight right there was the real
start of it all,
you know,
in terms of public perception.
Exactly,
exactly.
I knew I was really going somewhere with
that,
especially when it went viral and then
coming back with Ortiz made it cause
people would have made it that much more
interesting to see what I'm going to do
now because people tune in now whether
they they love me or hate me,
they tuned into seeking.
I'm not next personnel.
Yeah.
No.
At this point in time,
trt bell TRT Vito Belfort forever.
That was when he was on trt.
He was a different kind of human being.
He was just completely different than he
is in every circumstance.
Oh yeah.
Looking back,
you can
see that.
I mean,
because when I fought him,
I fought him on trt.
You found him when he was at though the
super victorious.
Absolutely.
Looked like fucking the incredible hulk,
but muscles on his fucking eyebrows.
Yeah.
Looking back you can see that,
you know,
but at the time as a fighter you got to
be.
You can't think like that,
you know what I mean?
What are they looking at it?
That doesn't even do it just doesn't do
it justice that's supposed to be before
and after.
And
I'm just recovering from a cold or the
week.
I'm a little congested so I keep
coughing.
The real,
the real key.
It's a better one.
That's better.
That's way better.
That's much more accurate.
And he's
the guy who was known to take things,
took things early in his career.
Remember when he fought randy when he
was 19,
he was 240 pounds.
Yeah,
exactly his next start at the top of his
head.
But um,
yeah,
I remember there was a picture of us
both on the scale in Brazil and you
know,
looking back now years,
Holy Shit,
you know,
anyone else with the guys kinda big blah
blah blah blah blah,
but you don't think like that the time
you can't as a fight,
if you start having those thoughts,
those doubts start looking at fight his
physique and thinking,
oh,
he looks good.
You've already lost,
you know.
But in hindsight,
you can look back and say,
holy fuck,
what was I thinking?
You know,
this guy's fucking body out of his mind.
I remember on there,
I was trying to get a rise out of him
and he kept putting his hand in my face.
I'm not a religious guy and you know,
God bless anyone that is,
you know,
I mean that I respect everyone's
opinions,
but I'm not in as we know,
veto is heavily religious.
And he kept sticking this thing in my
face.
He was pissing me off.
Come here,
come here.
And he leans in.
I said,
there is no Jesus
made.
Maybe there is,
maybe there isn't,
you know,
me getting a job with a head kick in the
second round,
but maybe that was God the watting may
who knows?
What did he say?
Some fucking project is bullshit.
So the drug actually prolongs were
intensifies the depression,
you know,
maybe.
Okay.
For very short term use of very severe
depression,
but these are not things you want to go
on and stay on for a length of time.
What's fascinating to me is when I talk
to people that are on them that want to
talk to you,
like they're on some cancer medication
or they're on something that cures
polio,
like they,
they make it seem like you're
insensitive to the possibility that
there's other solutions.
Right.
And there were many other solutions.
We have really good evidence for the
antidepressant effect of physical
activity.
Yes.
Both to prevent and treat.
We have very good evidence for
supplemental fish oil or omega three
fatty acids to permit and CBDS.
Well and the microbiome looks like it's
involved in our mental states as well.
So,
you know,
there's so many different ways.
Yes,
CBD for sure.
So again,
gets back to inflammation it and it gets
back to in an integrative approach and
not just relying on a single thing like
a pharmaceutical treatment.
Yeah,
I've talked to intelligent people that
are on Ssri in one form or another and
even ones that have struggled were on
one for a while and then it stopped
working and then they tried another one
and they're combining ones and they're
on this weird sort of chemical
rollercoaster and they reject any
possible notion that there's other
alternatives.
Especially when you bring up the
exercise one,
right?
I bring up the exercise one,
they go,
oh,
this fucking meathead exercise.
We just stop and I'm like,
I'm telling you.
We did this thing with my friends called
sober October and what we did is we no
alcohol,
no anything for the month of October,
but also we did this fitness challenge
and we got really carried away and we're
all competing against each other with
this heart rate app.
So we're working out three hours,
four hours a day.
It was crazy.
But what was interesting about it to me
was not just that your body sort of
adapts when you force it to work that
many hours,
but that your mood is phenomenal.
I felt so good.
Yeah.
And I was telling everybody,
if you could take what I like,
I don't feel that good right now.
I mean I felt great,
but I don't feel as good as I did during
October because I was working out four
hours a day.
It was.
If you could get that in pill form,
you would take it every day if there was
no side effects because it literally
removed anxiety.
All the internal chatter,
all the negative chatter,
it was gone.
Everything seemed amazing.
True.
And there are side effects of physical
activity are great.
You know,
it revs up immune function,
improves the gesture and sleep,
all that you mentioned,
the anxiety,
the by far and away,
the most effective treatment I found for
anxiety is simple.
A simple breathing technique,
regulating the breath.
I've seen this work for the most extreme
forms of panic disorder and the drugs
that we use for anxiety or the worst.
The benzodiazepines are highly
addictive.
Mess with your mind.
Yeah.
I have a good friend who has an issue
with anxiety medication and he takes it
all the time and when he does take it,
apparently it has that rebound effect
exactly right.
He gets horribly anxious.
Well,
these are handed out like candy and
nobody warns people how addictive they
are.
Worse addiction than an opiate.
Addiction.
Xanax really?
Well.
I did not know that.
Harder to get off of the opioids.
Wow.
Because out of all those voices,
as long as you're not personally trying
to figure it out and filter it yourself
with your own,
which is completely impossible,
but if you could just look at it
objectively from afar,
this is going to work itself out in a
far better way than has ever happened
before.
In our past.
There's never been this many voices and
our pastor has been like you were
talking about a select few voices.
The Walter cronkite's,
the whoever it is at the top,
and then everyone else sort of had to
wait for the narrative to be spelled out
for them.
That's not the case anymore.
That's right.
And,
and again,
I think it's the best of times in the
worst of times,
the best of times because all these new
voices are bringing all sorts of great
perspective and insight and intelligence
to the story that wasn't there before.
And that's great.
The problem is,
is if the infrastructure that used to be
there to kind of bring us all Paul bring
us all up to kind of basic level so that
we understood the facts disappears so
they,
we don't have anything that kind of
makes it so that we all understand
what's at issue and what's at stake and
what the facts are so that we can act as
a democracy in a sensible way.
Then the question is how do we run a
democracy?
You know,
because if we could have all these
different,
you know,
I like to think about the difference
between the culture channel and the
democracy channels.
So in the culture channel,
this is the best of times by orders of
magnitude and the stuff on television
today is a billion times better than
anything from the 19 seventies in 19
eighties.
Yeah.
And it's,
that's a product of this incredible
competition and the fact that you can
have anything and any niche market and
as long as it's enough,
it makes sense to do it and that's
what's great.
But when you turn to the democracy
channel,
the same fragmentation,
the same niche market,
the same reality of us all living in
these different universes means we can't
address problems as a democracy with
even the same facts.
And that's a real problem because if we
all live in our own fact universe,
but we have to same face,
the same real problems in the same real
earth,
then we're not going to decide them in
any sensible way.
And how you solve that problem is really
hard.
Like we're not going back.
Thank God we're not going back to the 19
sixties.
It's just not going to be the case that
there are three channels we get to
watch.
That's just not gonna happen.
Um,
and,
and it's a great thing because we've got
all this amazing culture,
but what do we do on the democracy side?
How do we build a democracy,
recognizing that everybody's not going
to spend all their time geeking out
about campaign finance reform
legislation.
I.
And that's why I think we need to think
about these other ways to bring people
to some sensible understanding.